You've already seen
some of those tricks.
I asked you to make your inputs zero
mean and equal variance earlier.
It's very important for SGD.
I also told you to initialize
with random weights
that have relatively small variance,
same thing.
I'm going to talk about a few more
of those important tricks, and
that should cover all you really need
to worry about to implement SGD.
The first one is momentum.
Remember that at each step, we're taking
a very small step in a random direction,
but that on aggregate, those steps take
us toward the minimum of the loss.
We can take advantage of
the knowledge that we've accumulated
from previous steps about
where we should be headed.
A cheap way to do that is to keep
a running average of the gradients, and
to use that running average instead
of the direction of the current
batch of the data.
This momentum technique works very well
and often leads to better convergence.
The second one is learning rate decay.
Remember, when replacing gradient
descent with SGD, I said that we were
going to take smaller,
noisier steps towards our objective.
How small should that step be?
That's a whole area of research as well.
One thing that's always the case,
however,
is that it's beneficial to make that
step smaller and smaller as you train.
Some like to apply an exponential decay
to the learning rate some like to make
it smaller every time the loss reaches
a plateau, there are lots of ways to go
about it, but lowering it over
time is the key thing to remember.